Peter durante Tommen is best known for
overhauling the PC port of Dark Souls
with dsfix a texture mod that made
significant visual improvements over the
vanilla version of the game though there
is as of yet no dsfix to Durante has
been hard at work on his latest mod the
ambitious G dosa tube or general down
sampling tool the tool enables games to
run at ridiculously high resolutions and
then down samples them to a super crisp
1080p this is only the beginning however
as the mod also adds a handful of
options for improving Dark Souls 2 s
overall appearance the most noticeable
change comes from the post-processing
option this is the equivalent of color
correcting the entirety of your Dark
Souls 2 experience colors become deeper
and more vibrant and contrast is
markedly improved with post-processing
enabled medulla feels like a sunset
drenched abandoned village instead of a
drab grey clearing with a few buildings
this effect alone is worth grabbing G
dosa to the mods anti-aliasing toggle
makes little difference when down
sampling no matter how hard you push it
but it's useful for running the game at
lower resolutions that create jaggies
and other visual aberrations otherwise
it's probably just sucking up some of
your resources and should be disabled
the depth of field option adds blur to
objects proportional to their distance
from your point of view this is
comparable to the effect of a camera
lens set to a wide aperture though some
may find it odd to consider the blurring
of objects of visual improvement shallow
depth of field lens dark souls2 a
cinematic feel and renders backdrop
elements in a dreamy haze that adds to
the mystique of drangleic the ambient
occlusion option defines how exposed
certain elements are to the ambient
lighting in an area enabling ambient
occlusion adds a touch of shadow to the
edges of objects and give us a lifelike
appearance to the finer details of the
world such as stonework statues flora
characters clothing and armor etc this
effect is resource intensive so if
you're just barely pumping out a stable
framerate this may be the option to
disable first but it is a nice touch if
you've got power to spare Dorantes G
dosa 2 is an impressive mod that renders
the PC port of Dark Souls 2 its
definitive version until dsfix 2 comes
out and for the love of God well
somebody please give Durante a job on
the next Souls game
[Music]